GOOD NIGHT, EVERYBODY.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
HERE’S SOMETHING YOU PROBABLY
DIDN’T KNOW.
CONGRESSWOMAN
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ, THE
VOICE OF THE STREET, ACTUALLY
GREW UP IN IDYLLIC TOWN 45 MILES
NORTH OF NEW YORK CITY.
IT’S CALLED YORKTOWN HEIGHTS.
YOU NEVER KNOW IT FROM LISTENING
TO HER RECENT RACE BAITING BUT
THE POPULATION OF ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO CORTES’ HOME IS OVER 90%
WHITE.
THE MEDIAN FAMILY INCOME IS MORE
THAN DOUBLE THE NATIONAL
AVERAGE.
REAL ESTATE LISTINGS SHOW
MILLION-DOLLAR HOMES ON BIG
PIECES OF GATED PROPERTY.
IT’S NOT QUEENS.
IT’S A NICE PLACE.
YORKTOWN HEIGHTS IS SO AFFLUENT
AND SO PEACEFUL, IN FACT IT
DOESN’T NEED ITS OWN POLICE
DEPARTMENT.
INSTEAD IT RELIES ON THE 59 MAN
FORCE THAT PROTECTS THE LARGER
TOWN AROUND IT.
THIS IS THE HOOD THAT SPAWNED
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ, ONE OF
THE COUNTRY’S MOST PRIVILEGED
REVOLUTIONARIES.
SHE CALLED HERSELF SANDY CORTEZ
BACK THEN.
SHE IMAGINED EVERYPLACE COULD BE
JUST LIKE YORKTOWN HEIGHTS IF
ONLY WE GOT RID OF THE POLICE.
APPARENTLY SHE STILL BELIEVES
THAT.
>> IT’S FUNNY BECAUSE WHEN
PEOPLE ASK ME WHAT IS A WORLD
WHERE WE DEFUND THE POLICE, WHAT
THE DEFUNDING OF POLICE LOOKS
LIKE, I TELL THEM IT LOOKS LIKE
A SUBURB.
>> Tucker: IT LOOKS LIKE A
SUBURB.
UNFORTUNATELY NOT EVERYONE LIVES
IN A SUBURB AS PLACID AND
PROTECTED THE ONE SANDY CORTEZ
GREW UP IN.
POOL PARTIES.
CITIES LIKE ST. LOUIS AND
BALTIMORE ARE MORE VIOLENT THAN
EL SALVADOR AND THEY’RE GETTING
MORE DANGEROUS BY THE DAY.
IN MILWAUKEE, HOMICIDES OF HIS
NEARLY 40% JUST THIS YEAR,
KILLING SURROGATES AND BREAK THE
CITY’S ALL-TIME RECORD.
THAT’S LIKELY TO HAPPEN SOON IN
CHICAGO AND KANSAS CITY.
JUST THIS WEEKEND AND THE CITY
OF CHICAGO, 64 BIT WERE SHOT AND
11 MURDERED.
11 CORPSES IN ONE WEEKEND.
NONE OF THOSE PEOPLE DIED
BECAUSE THERE WERE TOO MANY COPS
ON THE STREET.
THEY DIED THANKS IN PART TO
SLOGANEERING FROM PAMPERED
DILETTANTES LIKE SANDY CORTEZ,
THERE WERE TOO FEW COPS.
LESS LAW ENFORCEMENT IN
DANGEROUS PLACES NEEDS MORE
KILLINGS.
THERE’S NOT MUCH DEBATE ABOUT
IT, AT LEAST NOT AMONG ADULTS.
NEW YORK CITY DISBANDED ITS
PLAINCLOTHES POLICE UNIT AND CUT
FUNDING FOR THE NYPD BY BILLION
DOLLARS.
THE RESULT?
SHOOTINGS IN NEW YORK ARE UP
MORE THAN 200% COMPARED TO THIS
TIME JUST LAST YEAR.
MURDERS ARE UP 21%.
BURGLARS HAVE RISEN 30%.
IT IS THE MOST DANGEROUS TIME TO
LIVE IN NEW YORK CITY IN A
QUARTER-CENTURY.
JUST LAST NIGHT, AND INFANT WAS
SHOT TO DEATH WHILE SLEEPING IN
A SMALL DOOR AT A COOKOUT IN
BROOKLYN.
MAYOR BILL de BLASIO, WHO IS A
SINGLE-HANDEDLY DESTROYED THAT
CITY, DESCRIBE THE CHILD’S
MURDER AS "SO PAINFUL."
THEN de BLASIO MOVE FORWARD
WITH HIS PLANS TO DISABLE THE
NYPD.
HE CANCELED THE HIRING OF MORE
THAN 1,000 COPS.
HE ANNOUNCED THE POLICE WOULD NO
LONGER KEEP SCHOOL SAFE.
HOW WILL IT END?
WE KNOW HOW VERY WELL IT WILL
END.
MORE POOR CHILDREN WILL DIE.
IT WILL NOT AFFECT
BILL de BLASIO, THOUGH.
HIS FAMILY WILL REMAIN PROTECTED
BY ARMED SECURITY PAID FOR BY
TAXPAYERS.
SO WILL SANDY CORTEZ.
SEVERAL BARACK OBAMA.
SO WILL THE REST OF THE
POLITICIANS CALLING FOR TAKING
AWAY OUR PROTECTION.
THEY WILL NEVER SUFFER THE
CONSEQUENCES.
THAT’S WHY THEY ARE FOR IT.
>> THE FOLKS IN LAW ENFORCEMENT
THAT SHARE THE GOALS OF
REIMAGINING POLICE.
SPEAKER REIMAGINING POLICING IN
THE 21ST CENTURY.
>> RETHINKING AND REIMAGINING
POLICING.
>> COMMUNITY EFFORTS TO
REIMAGINE POLICING.
>> TO REIMAGINE POLICING.
>> WE HAVE TO REIMAGINE WHAT
POLICING LOOKS LIKE.
>> REIMAGINING POLICING,
REIMAGINING OUR PUBLIC SAFETY.
SPEAKER IMAGINE A CITIZEN LED
APPROACH.
>> BEGIN TO REIMAGINE
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
>> REIMAGINE PUBLIC SAFETY IN
THIS COUNTRY.
>> WHAT CAN WE DO TO REIMAGINE
PUBLIC SAFETY?
>> REIMAGINE PUBLIC SAFETY.
SPEAKER REIMAGINE PUBLIC SAFETY.
>> WE MUST REIMAGINE PUBLIC
SAFETY LOOK LIKE.
>> Tucker: WE MUST REIMAGINE
PUBLIC SAFETY.
THAT’S OUR NEW TOPPING POINT
THAT IT WAS DEVISED BY
UPHOLSTERER AND THE DNC AND THEY
ARE ALL FAITHFULLY REPEATING IT
LIKE THE ROBOTS THEY ARE.
WHAT EXACTLY DOES IT MEAN?
MARK MCCLOSKEY DOESN’T HAVE TO
IMAGINE.
HE WAS A TEST CASE FOR REIMAGINE
AND PUBLIC SAFETY.
WHEN A MOB SHOWED UP OUTSIDE HIS
HOME AND THREATENED HIS LIFE,
THE POLICE NEVER CAME.
MCCLOSKEY AND HIS WIFE HAD NO
CHOICE BUT TO DEFEND THEMSELVES.
>> LET’S GO!
>> KEEP MOVING!
>> Tucker: FOR CENTURIES SINCE
THE BEGINNING OF RECORDED
HISTORY, SELF-DEFENSE HAS BEEN
THE MOST BASIC PRINCIPLE OF
CIVILIZATION, BUT NOW THE WAY OF
REIMAGINE PUBLIC SAFETY, IT’S
ILLEGAL.
WATCH CNN’S RESIDENT
BODY BUILDER EXPLAIN THE NEW
STANDARD.
KEEP IN MIND AS YOU WATCH THAT
THE GUY DOING THE LECTURING THIS
TAPE HAS REPEATEDLY THREATENED
VIOLENCE AGAINST OTHERS FOR
INVADING HIS PERSONAL SPACE.
BUT HE GETS TO DO THAT.
HIS BROTHER IS THE GOVERNOR.
>> THEY DID NOT GO UP YOUR
STEPS.
THEY DIDN’T GO TO YOUR HOUSE.
THEY DIDN’T TOUCH YOU.
THEY DIDN’T TRY TO ENTER YOUR
HOME.
THEY DIDN’T TRY TO DO ANYTHING
TO YOUR KIDS, BUT YOU SAY WERE
ASSAULTED.
YOU ARE USING THE SIMPLE
DEFINITION OF THAT WHICH IS THAT
YOU HAVE THE APPREHENSION THAT
SOMETHING BAD WAS GOING TO
HAPPEN TO YOU.
BUT NOTHING DID.
BUT TO CALL IT TERRORISM AND THE
PEOPLE ARE THERE PROTESTING HOW
THE COMMUNITY IS TREATED BY THE
POLICE IS A LITTLE BIT OF A
REVERSE PSYCHOLOGY AT MINIMUM,
IS IT NOT?
>> Tucker: IT’S HARD TO KNOW
EXACTLY WHAT WHAT THE CNN ANCHOR
TRYING TO SAY.
SOME OF THOSE SENTENCES DIDN’T
MAKE SENSE BUT YOU GET THE
LARGER POINT.
A HOMEOWNER SHOULD TRY TO
PROTECT THEMSELVES FROM VIOLENCE
ARE THE REAL TERRORISTS NOW AND
THEY MUST BE PUNISHED.
INCREASINGLY THEY ARE PUNISHED.
LISTEN TO THE LOCAL POLITICAL
HACKS PROSECUTOR IN ST. LOUIS
THREATENED TO HURT THE
MCCLOSKEYS FOR DARING TO DEFEND
THEMSELVES.
>> I’M DISTURBED BY THE EVENTS
THAT OCCURRED OVER THE WEEKEND
WHERE THERE WERE PEACEFUL
PROTESTERS WERE MET WITH GUNS
AND A VIOLENT ASSAULT.
LEARNING OF THE EVENTS OVER THIS
WEEKEND, I WORK WITH THE PUBLIC
AND THE POLICE TO INVESTIGATE
THESE TRAGIC EVENTS.
I WILL USE EVERY EXTENT OF
MISSOURI LAW TO HOLD INDIVIDUALS
ACCOUNTABLE.
>> Tucker: TURNS OUT SHE
WASN’T BLUFFING.
JUST A FEW DAYS AGO, POLICE